and another really dark uh finding is
uh that a recent study of 21 000 women
in 27 european countries found uh
consistently that women who were higher
educated are earning more than their
partners were much more likely to report
all types of intimate partner violence
and from an evolutionary psychology
perspective yeah it's not not good right
you know and uh that's maybe an
unintended consequence the way that
works is if you're a man with a higher
status mate who's spending a lot of her
time around other high status males
while you're away from her
that that gives you a cue that you might
be inclined to lose her and you actually
might
welcome to episode 159 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm mikayla peterson
this episode is everything you need to
know about incels in this episode i
spoke with william costello about in
cells you might be asking yourself why i
decided to dedicate an entire episode to
incels well recently william
wrote the first academic paper
discussing the psychology of incels and
he's incredibly well informed about the
topic and a few days ago as you guys
probably know dad was dubbed king and
god of the incels thanks to actress
olivia wilde olivia said the villain
played by chris pine in her new movie
don't worry darling is based on my dad
who she described as a
pseudo-intellectual hero to the insult
community so why not take this
opportunity to learn a bit about what
insults really are are they really evil
right-wing misogynists or something else
entirely william is also part of dr
david buss's evolutionary psychology lab
which is really cool in this episode we
discussed the characteristics of the
average incel the black pill world view
hypergamy mutual mate choice in men and
women socially enforced monogamy and
much more this episode is brought to you
by better fed beef if you've ever
wondered how long a human can only eat
lamb literally nothing else before
they're really tired of eating lamb well
i lasted two years and now i am back to
eating beef thank goodness because i'm
really tired of lamb i love lamb but
like i don't want to eat lamb forever at
this point better fed beef has ruined
restaurants for me because they're so
much better than eating out and i i i
really don't like like aged meat so
eating out is tricky
so thank you better fed for that they
produce high quality beef from cattle
raised by local farming partners in
small town usa their beefs unbelievably
tender a study at north dakota state
university found that better fed beef is
as tender as american wagyu
and at a fraction of the cost not
exactly sure why that university was
studying how tender beef is but hey
maybe that's why universities are
failing at least now we know better
fed's farms are run by 17 different
families across the midwest who care for
the cattle themselves they raise all of
their cattle following certified anya
standards controlling for genetics
animal care and raising practices
phd ruminant nutritionists you can
literally get a phd in anything the
podcast today is with a dude who
specializes in incels anyway these
ruminant nutritionists have optimized
the cow's diets to produce more high
quality and healthy cattle better fed
beef has the best tasting beef i've
tried out of a box and just in general
and i've really tried
all the beef that's available out of the
box they have tons of options like the
backyard barbecue box short ribs ground
beef they're low in slow box brisket etc
everyone can get healthier and stronger
if you add meat to your diet my
listeners can take a whopping 25 off
their first order by going to
betterfedbeef.com
and using promo code mp at checkout
their website is
betterfedbeef.com their motto is real
beef from real families try them out 25
off pretty big
mp
enjoy this episode
[Music]
william costello welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me on happy to be here
this should be this should be fun before
we get started can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
okay so um
last year in 2021 i graduated um from
brunel university in london with a
master's in psychology culture and
evolution and my dissertation uh focused
on investigating the underlying
psychology of in cells or involuntary
celibates it was one of the first
studies uh to include primary responses
from self-identified in-cells i'm
currently here in austin texas as a phd
student at the university of texas at
austin where i'm in david buss's
evolutionary psychology lab
and uh
yeah that's uh what my area of expertise
so far is intel psychology so hopefully
that will help with the conversation
that that should help with the
conversation a lot and you work with
david buss that's fun that's very cool
um okay so there's a bunch to cover but
we should probably first start off with
what exactly is an install
right so uh incel stands for involuntary
celibate and it's become kind of an
online subculture of primarily men um
who kind of form their sense of identity
around their perceived inability to form
sexual or romantic relationships they're
involuntarily uh celibate uh a
significant minority of incels are very
misogynistic and online they're very
hostile online uh but one study not my
own study found that just 10 of intel
accounts are responsible for the vast
majority of online hostility
and an even more rare uh
amount of in cells still actually lash
out that society in violent rage and
there's some high profile cases where
individual in cells have even gone on to
kill people most notorious is uh perhaps
eliot roger
who wrote a 49-page manifesto talking
about how he would have a day of
retribution
where he would kill chads and stacy's
who the the sexually successful men and
women that he was envious of and so he's
kind of held up as the prototypical
example poster boy incel
whenever the media reports on them but
even globally worldwide there's only
ever been approximately 60 deaths
attributable directly to in-cell
violence and i don't mean to demean and
any of the victims at all but but that's
relatively low when in cell violence is
talked about as the new terrorist threat
in the media sometimes
and so if we put that figure of 60 into
more context 10 of those alone can be
accounted for by a guy called alec
minassian and he's the guy who drove his
van into a crowd of people in toronto
yeah i remember that that was scary yeah
yeah and he he's often held up as front
and center as poster boy of the insult
movement as well in the media and
because he had a a facebook post before
he did what he did talking about how he
wanted to start an in-cell rebellion and
all hill the supreme gentleman earlier
roger and uh you know the beta uprising
has begun that that was his kind of
rhetoric but you don't often hear what's
reported
what's less often reported is the
judge's verdict in the case when they
analyzed all the evidence
the judge said that basically
they considered that alec manasian was
completely piggybacking on the incel
movement uh to ratchet up his own
notoriety
he deliberately told lies to depict the
killings as being connected to the incel
movement to get more media attention and
his story to the police about the attack
being an incel rebellion was a lie so
that's directly from the judge in the
alec menacing case you don't really hear
that talked about that often in the
media
no so was he was he an incel or
well it's difficult to kind of know he
he certainly seemed to use a lot of uh
in cell kind of rhetoric
in that initial that that post but that
was the verdict of the judge and the
lawyers closest to the case
interesting okay so
what made you
decide to kind of base your education
around this particular subject
right so when i came to look into the
topic which i think is a very
interesting one
because the incel
culture
for me kind of describes where our
evolved map preferences our evolutionary
psychology meets cultural psychology and
cultural kind of advances
so it was very interesting for me on
that front and also when i came to do my
literature review
for the topic i found that at the time
almost no studies included primary
responses from in cells themselves all
the studies were based on and analyzing
the online misogyny or the online
rhetoric of incidentals and
being quite familiar just
in the online world of the enceladus
sphere i kind of had an inkling that a
lot of what in themselves say online is
deliberately antagonistic and just kind
of performatively antagonistic that they
kind of say anything they feel will
subvert the norm and will annoy people
and just
you know they're very steeped in dark
gallows humor mean culture and so you
know it it although analyzing the online
misogyny is somewhat useful and
i don't i think you actually need to
engage with the community
one-to-one or directly to form any kind
of psychological opinion
i'm also interested in incels because
uh
this demographic of young men
traditionally in evolutionary psychology
we have something called young male
syndrome and basically young male
syndrome is the consistent
cross-cultural cross-historical finding
that
in any population when you have a
surplus population of unpartnered young
men of sexless young men uh they cause a
lot of crime and they disrupt society a
lot this is kind of that they usually
have like elevated status-seeking
behaviors and risk-taking and so it's
actually quite dangerous and uh
historically there's been lots of kind
of institutions developed to even deal
with um
individual nations surplus population of
young men so for example the portuguese
who when they maybe went sailing to
discover new worlds
there are some theories that that was
basically a a device to cope with your
surplus population of young men you
could just send them off on a mission
and uh vikings would be another example
we tend to think of vikings as perhaps a
very sexy kind of rugged maybe the
hollywood kind of viking isn't probably
really typical of what a viking was like
uh in reality they were more likely your
surplus population wow
yeah there's a really cool article in
the online magazine called uh unheard
and by mary harrington uh she wrote an
article talking about how incels could
become the new vikings so you know we
have a good lot of reason to worry about
this population this kind of surplus
population of unpartnered young men who
are galvanizing around this idea and
seem to have a lot of resentment but you
would actually expect them to be a lot
more destructive than they actually
currently are being and you know
i mentioned earlier that 60 deaths
worldwide 10 of which can be attributed
to one man alone who may or may not even
have been that very much linked to the
in-cell movement so the idea behind why
they're not more destructive uh
we maybe think that they might just have
their status striving psychology
mechanisms hijacked by online worlds
pornography the forums just oh
[ __ ] posting online yeah so it there's a
lot going on with this community i think
they're and i also think that the
mainstream media narrative of about in
cells is very insufficient and
culturally i think we kind of
sneer at the insult problem a little bit
and uh it's my opinion that the insult
problem is just a symptom of what i
would call a wider mage in crisis that
hurts everybody not just disenfranchised
young men
how large is this crisis like when i
hear incel i kind of think of like a
very
very small
part of the population i don't think of
that as a lot of people and
i hope it's not a lot of people because
it is kind of
sad and unfortunate uh so how many
people are we talking about here or what
percentage of the population actually
identify as in cells so it really
depends on
i sound a little bit like your father
jordan peters is in there saying it
depends on what you mean and
it does depend on what you mean by incel
so a smaller significant minority of the
population
but we're talking less than a hundred
thousand i would say i would estimate
and then someone would probably correct
me if i'm wrong there would actually
identify online in the online subculture
but then if you define incel as you know
just a a man who's struggling to to get
sex those are arising all the time and
there's a figure that the share of u.s
men younger than 30 reporting having no
sex within the last year rose from 8 in
2008 to 28
in 2018.
what 2018. so that's before covid
right yeah so that was
yeah and actually there's some evidence
that that might be reversing a little
bit probably due to covert because men
would actually be like risk-taking so
that the percentage of men is kind of go
they would actually risk breaking code
lockdown to have sex but yeah that's a
that's kind of a worrying trend of
sexlessness but a figure to kind of put
with that is that
it's not all men that are getting more
sexless uh there's a small minority of
men at the top that are doing very well
so to put that into context compared to
2002 men overall had the same number of
sex partners in 2013 but the top 20 of
men had a 25
increase in sexual partners and the top
five percent of men had an even more
dramatic 38
increase so you can kind of see this
skew happening uh whereby a lot of men
are being left out some men are being
very very successful and it kind of
maybe points that in cells are maybe
partially accurate in their assessment
of some aspects of the mating market
that there may be well a handful of
chads who are
reluctant to commit um long term who are
just um really enjoying the short-term
mating market
huh okay wow that's really interesting
why would there be that increase is that
social media like how are these like
top market men getting so many more
women than they were before
well i think that
there is like online dating apps give
them kind of a device to maybe access uh
you know and without incurring the
reputational costs of being a short-term
major that you might have in our
ancestral environment certainly or even
just before online dating you can kind
of move city quite quickly or easily in
an online dating app context and there's
also kind of been a somewhat of a
cultural drive towards singlehood um
you know like even big companies are
kind of maybe encouraging women in
particular to kind of remain single and
with chris williamson we were talking
about a recent article whereby i was
highlighting how single women can earn a
lot more money and um you know they're
doing a lot better than single men in
their career and it's kind of this
maybe cultural drive to prioritize the
male default of the ceo boardroom badass
type feminism that that's seen as
priority over the
uh the kind of
the polar opposite of the trad wife uh
family-oriented woman it's it's kind of
maybe an acknowledgment that the gender
pay gap was never really revealed in so
far
it's more like a motherhood penalty and
that is where women do get punished is
women actually and certainly in the uk
earn just as much or even more than men
up until the age of 29 i believe and
then the motherhood penalty maybe kicks
in but it's only describing it as a
penalty if you consider the woman's own
income herself married women actually
their income would be more than the
single women
okay so looking at this from more female
more female perspective are women also
suffering from this kind of sexlessness
or is this mostly male focused
uh so
i'm always asked whether uh there's such
a thing as a femme cell a female in cell
and
initially i could i maybe would have i
could only find nine female in cells
from my study so i kind of didn't focus
on them yeah
and in cells would kind of say to you
there's no such thing as a female in
cell because uh most women um no matter
how low mate value they might be they
could probably go out and get sex or a
relationship if they wanted they just
might need to lower their standards and
initially i kind of thought yeah that
that maybe makes intuitive sense yeah
that's probably true and a lot of my
female friends would probably agree with
that but
uh
it i think that's a real failure of
cross-sex mind reading on the behalf of
incels because they see
a woman's ability to get something
rather than nothing they always see that
as better whereas for a woman
getting the sex or relationship that you
don't want is actually worse than
nothing it's cost inflicting and i think
instills really underestimate
how much women don't want to have sex
but then they don't want to have sex
with that's that's really bad for women
so they'd rather stay
and you know i i think about my female
friends and i wouldn't advise them to
settle for a man that they didn't want
or a relationship they didn't want and
it's kind of um an artifact of maybe
women's liberation into the workplace
and their socioeconomic success that
they don't have to perhaps settle for
men that they don't want and it might be
a dark
or a kind of uncomfortable truth for us
to acknowledge that maybe for the last
number of decades women had been perhaps
doing that out of strict uh socially
enforced monogamy which is a phrase that
your dad got in trouble for using yeah
we can talk about that a little bit
later yeah rm just out of strict
economic necessity so now women don't
really need to so they're not but what
what happens then
women's interest then is aimed kind of
hypergamously so that women tend to mate
across or up in status hierarchies and
um
you know if there's a with any sex ratio
if there's only a small amount of men
that are in women are interested in then
they call the shots and uh you know
women kind of
those small minority of men that women
are interested in are reluctant to
commit to long-term mating because
they're in the minority they're the
scarcity so they're not
they kind of create the rules of the of
the mating market so to speak now there
is some evidence that hypergamy so
women's tendency to mate up in status
hierarchies is declining a little bit in
recent years and i think i think that's
inevitable but with women's rapid
socioeconomic success but even the
authors of that study that showed that
hypergamy is in decline
they commented that they couldn't speak
to women's perceived difficulties in
accessing the mate
so they said oh maybe women aren't
actually that happy about it and another
really dark finding is
that a recent study of 21 000 women in
27 european countries found
consistently that women who were higher
educated are earning more than their
partners were much more likely to report
all types of intimate partner violence
and from an evolutionary psychology
perspective yeah it's not not good right
you know and
that's maybe an unintended consequence
and the way that works is if you're a
man with a higher status mate who's
spending a lot of her time around other
high status males while you're away from
her
that that gives you a cue that you might
be inclined to lose her and you actually
might and so
some men choose the strategy of cost
inflicting me retention strategies and
that's what the violence is the intimate
partner violence it's trying to
inflict so much cost on your partner
that it makes costly for them to leave
as to their self-esteem is lowered
they're um yeah they just think it would
be too costly to actually leave there's
also some evidence as well
that's really interesting that's really
interesting it's kind of like an
unintended consequence because you know
you tend to think of you know women's
socio-economic success as just a net
good and it has been for like um
economically and
for a country's gdp and things like that
but you know there's a maybe a bigger
picture to think about and
you have capitalist capitalist giants
like morgan stanley they released a
forecast called the rise of the she
economy and predicting that 45
of working age women
and
between the ages of 25 and 44 would be
single and childless by the uh by the
year 2030 that's the largest share in
recorded history up from 41 in 2018
so you can see that their
capitalist giants are putting the foot
to the floor on this she economy badass
feminism because they get access to
worker drones who will work 60 hour work
weeks and you might recall michaela do
you remember that uh new yorker um cover
it had a like a picture and maybe you
can get it up on the screen and in the
edit it shows a woman kind of living in
a
kind of like a bachelor pad it's really
messy kind of home office and she's in
her flip-flops at the with the glass of
wine at her laptop and uh it's kind of
talking like seeming to suggest that
this is the vision women should strive
for
yeah it looked a bit bleak for me but
i'm kind of libertarian in my
sensibilities i kind of like more more
freedom the better yeah yeah me too but
more
i feel like stay-at-home mom or kind of
that traditional kind of um
role is a bit more demeaned in the
mainstream certainly oh 100 it's more
demeaned i think there's also like
there's also a major issue with it that
i think
most countries aren't tackling with
being a stay-at-home mom it's like maybe
one of the ways to encourage that is we
lower taxes for people who have kids
right i know um i think it's hungary i
think and i think people will correct me
if i'm wrong about this but i think it's
if if a woman has more than four kids
she doesn't pay income tax anymore
and like those kind of incentives to
kind of modernize staying at home
otherwise you do lose half your income i
mean you gain kids
right
but
yeah it's a complicated issue i'm also
wondering if some of these women who
don't end up getting into relationships
because
they don't like like you said you don't
want you really don't want to have sex
with someone you don't want to have sex
with um i don't
i don't think uh you probably know more
about this but i don't think women have
the same urges either like i don't i
don't think i think you can go
personally i know like i can go six or
seven months not have sex and i don't
really feel that much different than i
did at the very beginning of that like
there's i'm like okay like there's not
some sort of
urge to go have sex that there wouldn't
have been at the very beginning i don't
know if it differs from for in cells or
people who can't have sex where it's
like the longer it goes the worse you
feel
yeah there's certainly a sex difference
there in sexual psychology and the the
the effect sizes of the differences
between men and women in sexual
psychology are some of the biggest in
all of psychology the there are the
effect sizes that are basically like the
equivalent of the differences between
men and women in upper body strength so
that's almost unheard of in psychology
so that's huge but those are average
group differences right there's
obviously individual differences between
you know some women would have maybe
more male typical sex drive but yeah the
the kind of desire for frequency of sex
variety of sex partners number of sex
partners is always generally much more
among men and that makes sense and your
father kind of hinted at this um when he
said about women being choosy in this
video he talked about well you'd be
choosy too if you got pregnant or
potentially might have got get pregnant
every time you had sex and if we think
about like birth control is uh
has just been developed in the blink of
an eye over our evolutionary history so
our psychological
effect psychology mechanisms evolved in
a world without any you know
contraception and things like that where
pregnancy and giving birth and
carrying a child was very very dangerous
and risky for a woman and you know a lot
of um mortality during childbirth things
like that so you know it's a it's not
really surprising that that biological
difference between men and women that
greater parental investment
you know the the the most amount of
offspring
of children that a single woman has had
is 69 right and that sounds like a lot
right that sounds like a lot for one
single woman but men
yeah
that that's a really annoying is that
was that like
triplets repeatedly for
a number of triplets for sure but nine
did you say 69 69 is the highest right
but that's nothing compared to some men
like genghis khan for example is
reported to have thousands of offspring
so you know for a woman she can only
have a limited amount like 69 is a crazy
69
you know that's like we recognize that's
crazy extreme uh but for a man
theoretically there's no limit
all it takes is one successful sex fact
which um i'm reliably informed can take
just as quick as three minutes so yeah
but that's not speaking from personal
experience
but uh yeah theoretically unlimited
amount um but you know the human male
invests a lot more in their offspring uh
than
vast majority of other mammals it's um
but but nowhere near as much as the
human female
interesting okay so
throughout your studies um have you
identified what the average in cell
looks like
uh something like
my quantitative study didn't uh look at
their looks at all uh but i have
interviewed some
um
qualitatively in one-to-one interviews
over zoom but but i wouldn't like to
comment one way or the other what they
look like no no i mean i i i don't mean
looks like exactly in that way i mean
like characteristics
sure okay my dad would have corrected me
on that and like that's a bad question
you posed a bad question but yeah
characteristics of the average in itself
because what you hear online is kind of
what you said earlier which is like
violent aggressive women hating
dangerous so what do they actually look
like okay so i can talk through some of
some of the data that i found so one of
the things we investigated was their
levels of well-being because uh men's
sense of their own mate value is a
direct proxy for self-esteem right you
can actually track the two things track
each other very well and so we
hypothesize that in cells that have very
low levels of well-being and they did
they had um higher levels of depression
anxiety and loneliness lower levels of
satisfaction with life but just to put
that into context for you of just how
bad the levels of well-being are we used
the phq-9 and the gad7 which are
instruments to measure depression and
anxiety that are used by the nhs in the
uk
to clinically diagnose um patients with
depression and anxiety so we found that
roughly 73 of in cells could be
clinically diagnosed using that criteria
as severely or moderately severely
depressed versus 33
of non-insults in terms of anxiety we
found that roughly 67 of themselves
could be diagnosed as severely or
moderately uh anxious versus 38
of non-in cells
and
we found that they scored higher on
what's called sociosexual desire which
is um basically like the desire to have
um
uncommitted sex so to short-term mating
so they're high levels of desire and
that tracks a lot of data where
men who feel that they can't
get get sex in their behavior their
desire goes up we also found that incel
scored very high on a new personality
construct called the tendency for
interpersonal victimhood and uh that's
kind of uh leads to like an external or
an external locus of control which means
that you feel that your life and
everything that happens to you is
completely outside of your own control
that you can't control it and
the tendency for interpersonal
victimhood is comprised of four
different dimensions the first one is a
need for recognition so it's like a
preoccupation with having the legitimacy
of your grievance acknowledged so for
incels
i've noticed that one of the worst
things you can say to them to make them
feel bad is you don't look so bad or you
don't have it so bad you could get a
girlfriend for sure yeah they hate that
they want you to actually say no you
know what you're right and
you have a real problem here
the second dimension is moral elitism so
the belief that the individual or their
in-group behaves more morally
than others and that you can kind of see
that in in cells whereby they may be
poke
they highlight how superficial the
mating market is how stacy and chad are
kind of you know a bit superficial and
maybe they have a little bit of a point
but uh incels might suggest that their
um mating preferences would be a little
bit more
uh moral or intellectual
uh the third
dimension is a lack of empathy so the
way this transpires is that because in
cells have been hurt in the past they
feel entitled to hurt others nobody
cares about my feelings why should i
care about anyone else's and the final
one is rumination um
so constantly a preoccupation with
playing back perceived instances of
rejection and or
hurt over and over in your own head and
this idea of a tendency for
interpersonal victimhood the external
locus of control makes a lot of sense
when you think about the incel black
pill
philosophy or the black pill world view
sorry are you familiar with black pill
yeah let's do that what is the black
pill world view sure so the black pill
is the derivative of the concept of the
red pill from the movie the matrix and
the red pill denotes a kind of a
willingness to see the world as it
really is as opposed to taking the
blissful ignorance of the blue pill
the black pill then for incels refers to
their belief that there is nothing and
there was never nothing that they could
do to improve their romantic prospects
and it's kind of entered into just very
online parallels now that people are
black-pilled on various type of things
right yeah it's just a kind of a cynical
attitude uh but the black pill kind of
world view
uh
kind of captures
one of the only things that i think a
large swell of in cells kind of agree on
you know same
it's hard to get them to agree on a lot
of things but uh they seem to agree on
that one
do you think this increase in
uh um
sexlessness and i guess
to the in-cell community is it possible
that the community itself seems larger
because they have access to these forums
online so it's like oh there's lots of
people out there like me
is that possible
yeah i think so and you know given that
just 10 of intel accounts the most
extreme minority within the community do
most of the talking and shout the
loudest and they're the ones we tend to
focus on certainly in the media so it
maybe gives us the impression that
there's far more in cells
who think like this but yeah the in cell
kind of depending on how you define
hidden cell it could be larger or
smaller
um
but yeah yeah that's certainly a
possibility but one thing i definitely
think for in cells is that we live in a
kind of like a sex saturated world or we
get the impression that we do anyway so
you walk through a city you see
billboards of really attractive men and
women uh you watch tv and there's
amazing sex on every every show because
it sells
you know you get this kind of impression
that everyone is having an amazing sex
life but actually it's not true people
often overestimate the amount of sex
other people are having so that might be
one avenue to maybe help in cells
realize that they're not
suffering as uniquely because one
interesting finding from covert was that
in cell mental health actually there's
some evidence to show that in-cell
mental health got a little bit better
during covet because it was like for
them they were thinking well everybody's
experiencing what i'm experiencing all
the time now so that was a
kind of a paradoxical finding
uh the one positive of covid yeah right
and they're kind of like cynical in
cells so maybe they'd be like oh if i
can't have any i'm glad no one else can
either yeah yeah feel better about other
people's suffering as well so a couple
of other things we found about the incel
kind of demographic just said that the
last few things there
we investigated their socioeconomic
status because you know we figured that
socioeconomic status there's a large
body of evidence from evolutionary
psychology that socioeconomic status
matters a lot to women in the mating
market uh so we wanted to investigate
that and we found that 50 of in cells
versus 27 of non-in cells in our sample
still live with a parent or carer and
you might say oh well in cells are just
very young men so they just haven't
moved out but the average age for in
cells in our study
was 27 so
you know you'd expect perhaps they
should have moved out by then
uh 17 of in cells compared to 9 of
nonlin cells in our sample reported to
be neat which stands for not in
education employment or training
so they don't seem to have much job
prospects and 36 percent of in cells
versus roughly 20 percent of non-in
cells have a high school education or
lower uh so on all those kind of data
points they're a little bit uh kind of
being left behind and another thing we
wanted to investigate was um in the
media in cells are commonly and even in
this latest olivia wilde uh article
described as kind of largely
overwhelmingly white and white
supremacist almost and far right so we
wanted to investigate the ethnicities
and um
political affiliations and we found that
36
of in cells were in cells of color and
in a largely uk and u.s sample that's
actually over representative and
compared to all our participants of
non-in cells and in cells we can analyze
whether
it's actually more than you would expect
by mere chance and it it was
significantly more than you would expect
by mere chance compared to the rest of
the sample
in terms of their political affiliation
and i just asked one question in a large
study and in my paper i recommend that
we investigate political beliefs a
little bit more but we found that
roughly 39 percent reported that their
right leaning in their political
affiliation 45 reported to be left
leaning some more
meaning and 17
said they were centrist
and other studies have found that just
three percent of incel posts online
could be considered racist and meanwhile
30 percent of insult threads in their
forums could be considered misogynistic
and and that same study found that
self-hatred was by far the most common
form of toxic language so yeah it's it's
um we're asked a lot of times um to
think about in cells in terms of
extremism and it might be the case that
extreme in seldom actually looks more
like suicidality than
extremism yeah there's a high level of
82 of themselves in their own internal
survey from the forums indicated that
they had strongly considered suicide in
their life which is kind of stark and
there's another really good study
by dr sarah daley
uh called goodbye my friend cells and it
documents kind of online rhetoric in the
forums of suicidality and you know which
is so prevalent
in my gosh that's horrible yeah she even
highlights like some cases where maybe
someone has wrote a last post and then
they've never heard from again and we
don't know whether that person actually
went on to commit suicide it's kind of
sad yeah
oh that's that's really depressing i
think so when this olivia wild thing
happened with my dad i called him
and told him about it you know hero to
the incels um and his like i didn't put
everything he said online i caught some
of it and put it in a reaction video but
his main reaction was
we should be
you know trying to solve this problem
and feeling not feeling sorry for
exactly but having compassion towards
these people because it's actually like
sad you know and you can you can't
like as an in spell you wouldn't want to
be angry and misogynistic and hateful um
but he said what he was working on was
taking like lost men in particular and
saying hey you have the power to improve
your life and if you improve your life
then everything around you will improve
right including
probably you being an incel right
because there are things you can do
about it um
i would assume i mean that's depending
on your situation yeah that's like it
depends on what you mean by in-cell
savior or in-cell god even yeah
might be actually more appropriate
because his tough love pick yourself up
build yourself up tidy your room develop
yourself yeah interesting might actually
be what in cells might need but
in terms of oh install
representative he goes counter to the
intel world view you know his whole idea
is if every woman thinks this about you
they're right and so you know that uh
what you said about
your dad his work often is about
helping young men in particular or
everyone uh cultivate that internal
locus of control which our study shows
that in cells lack and
so you know i'm even an example of one
when i started listening to your dad in
like 2016 and 2017
and started like applying some of his
principles my life kind of trajectory
started to get a lot better and
i'm amazed at where it took me so
i can totally that's the individual
personal advice i would think that
listening to jordan peterson
self-development advice would would
perhaps be good for themselves but they
hate that rhetoric they hate that idea
of being told you need to develop you
can do some yeah well that that's kind
of interesting though because i feel
like you can see that in
a lot of groups like um
you know my back story probably a little
bit with the autoimmunity i had a
just a horrible autoimmune disorder and
when i was really sick i was in some of
these groups for people with autoimmune
disorders on facebook um and it was
mostly to like talk to other people to
try and figure out how to get out of it
right like hey have you figured out a
medication that works and all these
things those groups are just like that's
just hell on earth those groups they're
very depressing um but when i finally
figured out that there was a solution
out of it for me anyway with diet um
you can't communicate that into it and i
remember people coming to me when i was
very sick
saying like have you tried diet and i
always took it as a slight and i think
it was kind of condescending like oh
you're doing something wrong and that's
why you're in this situation and so
that's not a good way to communicate
something especially if you're trying to
get somebody to change um but i do
remember scoffing at people who told me
oh you should exercise more you should
diet um
and being angry
right and being angry about that so i
can kind of understand like if someone's
telling you hey if you did things you
could get out of the situation you're in
it's like well how dare you you don't
know how serious the situation i'm in is
yeah right and that really very much
applies to in cells because it's kind of
a wallowing in victimhood uh
ecosystem so a lot of in cells might
even if an individual in cell reports
having romantic success or having a date
or something like that the other incels
might kick him out of the forum or say
he's a fake cell and he wasn't ever
really
struggling and you know so he loses all
that fraternity and friendship
as well but yeah that's your dad's
message is you can only focus on the
sovereignty of the individual it's very
unlikely that you can change the world
around you sufficiently to to make it so
much better for you but what you can't
control is how you behave how you act in
the world whether you tilt the world
towards heaven or hell in every day make
tomorrow better than yesterday like that
that is so much about this individual
and uh what you can change but yeah
that's an antithetical to in cells who
say blackpill thinking it's over there
was no point in trying
jordan peterson's message would be
there's always hope and worth trying you
know that you can always affect change
in your life
is there overlap between the insult
group and kind of the serious
um
i would i don't exactly know what even
to call that group men's rights activism
but that's not what it is it's it maybe
it's called a black pill community
online uh is that what it is
manis fear yeah is there like an overlap
there or those two separate things as
well
i think insults are often kind of thrown
in whenever the manosphere is talked
about in like uh on online articles or
new media articles but the manosphere is
a kind of a broad church and and a lot
of
areas of the atmosphere would probably
sneer at themselves and look down on
them so it's not like it's this
collective
sphere it's in
different facets of it like mgtow which
is kind of like in cells but it stands
for men going their own way and that's
for men who think that they probably
could get sex their relationships but
think that it's worth not worth their
trouble so they're kind of going their
own way and they would maybe
differentiate themselves from themselves
and then there's red pill kind of
communities which is more like
trying to maybe the opposite of walk
of trying to wake people up in another
direction of this is how the amazing
market works and
these are all the tricks you need to
know and that kind of thing pick up
artists it's a broad church but i kind
of think that there is
there needs to be maybe space for
a foreign cells or for young men who are
struggling an ethical pick-up artist
culture because okay i can recognize
that the
pickup artist world has descended into
maybe toxicity and undertake might be an
example of that in the the extremes but
that doesn't mean that there's not
something worth salvaging there and
there's a lot of young men who are
really struggling
and your dad makes a good point uh when
he was asked um why do you care about
young men so much why why does it matter
if they're developed and he says well
women should care too don't they want
competent partners and that's a good
point it's like you know when one sex
loses the other sex loses too and so i
kind of i haven't given up hope on
ethical pickup artist kind of world but
it's funny because whenever you attach
the goal of achieving romantic success
to self-development for men it gets
framed as misogynistic and it's like oh
you're being manipulative even barack
obama in his autobiography he wrote um
about how he was reading different books
to impress different types of women and
he got lambasted in the media for a
short while saying oh that's so
manipulative and you know
for men listening that's intuitive that
you know get the goal get the girl
that's kind of like an intuitive
archetype for men always and ever and
you know your dad mentioned in this uh
olivia wilde kind of fiasco
in his original video that i kind of
highlighted when he talked about how
women are right he talks about how
female sexual selection is actually an
engine of evolution more generally and
that it the
the mind of one sex the mind of the
female actually shapes the body and the
mind of the other sex so whatever like
yeah
reward men will go out and do it's why
men have strived maniacally for status
and success and for you know generations
uh so it's a it's a real motivator and i
wouldn't uh be so hasty to take it away
from men it's uh you know
it's not to be trifled with scary that's
so so now
and now i suppose that's kind of ruled
by women on birth control right do you
know what percentages of women are on
birth control oh i don't but i'd say it
would be increasing
i can look that up but there's a really
good book on birth control by um my uh
a professor called sarah hill and she
was in the david bus lab previously uh
to me and she wrote a book called this
is your brain on birth control and it
talks about
it's a really good book yeah and so i
direct your listeners to that one
not me you should maybe have her on the
show she's great okay yeah i'm gonna
write that down that that's a really
good idea no i'm yeah when i did some
research into birth control it's scary
and i remember being on birth control um
and my dad being who my dad is
we were kind of like i knew these things
like oh by the way if you're taking
birth control you might prefer like more
feminine men
like just that and and me being like
well i'll just
undo that in my head just like i'll just
be aware
like as a 19 year old being like i'll
just like keep that in mind like who i'm
attracted to like maybe go for the more
masculine person to die try and offset
this birth control which definitely
doesn't work it looks like 98 of
sexually active women have used birth
control and 62 62 of those of
reproductive age are currently using
birth control so that means what men are
doing in society or what they think is
attractive is being dictated by women on
birth control that's scary yeah it's
certainly like
bringing a bit more complexity to it
anyway and you know the hormones play a
lot into make choice and uh female
sexuality so yeah i think sarah hill
would be a better expert than me but it
definitely
you know it's not having no effect but
you know what you mentioned there of oh
i'll just override yeah preferences
i remember actually being in the
audience for one of your dad's talks in
like 2018 maybe or 20 2017.
and uh he gave us all a good classic
jordan peterson finger wagging and he
told us that he goes you have no idea
why you want what you want and i thought
it always resonated with me because a
lot of what the brain does and a lot of
our preferences is kind of cryptic to us
we don't actually know
so the idea that you know
you just can control your mate
preferences and you know even things
like offlactory cues like your sense of
scent you might really be attracted to
someone and then you get close to them
when you sniff them and oh whoa no
actually the attraction isn't there
so it's all
very cryptic so the idea of like a
hormonal birth control not having any
effect seems
strange to me
very very unlikely yeah uh what do you
think of this recent craze over andrew
tate
just like blowing up
yeah i'm not that familiar with him
either found any kind of time i've tried
to look into him i've found a lot of his
stuff seems a bit too unsavory for me i
think i think i saw a quote where he
said that
women are barely sentient but it kind of
like uh
it points to this idea if you leave a
vacuum of no real male role models
to kind of
emulate in striving for success in
achieving romantic success someone will
fill that vacuum and you might not like
what they're like and so
you know
i feel like there's a space there to be
filled and we can maybe do a bit better
than undertake but i'm not that familiar
with them
i wonder how many of his
clips that went viral were also taken
out of context i mean some of the things
he said are harsh like taken out of
context they're harsh but i wonder
i'm so skeptical i'm so skeptical of
things online after seeing like sound
bites of my dad being like yeah well if
you only cut that two and a half seconds
then i guess it doesn't sound great but
yeah yeah i've certainly seen that with
your dad but i don't know what preceding
context could be given to you or barely
sentient
no that's not that's not things of it
for me
i'm not that familiar
that's not ideal
um
interesting okay this socially enforced
monogamy okay okay yeah tell them tell
me about that
so your dad got in trouble for using
this phrase and
it actually points to a wide broadly
understood
kind of concept in mating literature so
basically what happens is that monogamy
is socially enforced you know it's not
um
we enforce it through norms if someone
cheats we think that's bad yeah you know
the common norm is to be monogamous
that's certainly culturally enforced
there's nothing controversial there but
what your dad was suggesting that it
might be a
a solution to the install problem or to
the surplus population of unpartnered
young men is actually also true so
there's really a good paper called the
puzzle of monogamous marriage by a
psychologist called joseph henrik
brilliant paper that talks about how
monogamy evolved as a cultural norm
because 83 percent of human societies
ever studied have been preferentially
polygenous meaning one man with multiple
female partners
that's right wait say that again
83 plus so and when i say preferentially
prolignous that doesn't mean that
everybody in that society would have
multiple wives you would have some with
multiple wives and many men
disenfranchised having none right so the
most high status men in those societies
might have one or two wives but it got a
little bit imbalanced and what happened
then was when you had the advent of
agriculture about 10 000 years ago uh
you had for the first time you had the
ability to stockpile resources so those
men at the top were able to attract such
inequality in terms of their resources
that they were able to attract
hundreds of wives or way more wives so
what happened then was the culturally
evolved norm those cultures that had a
norm of practicing monogamy basically
flourished and those that practiced
religion didn't because
if you
okay basically the main cultural
advantage of the monogamy is the more
egalitarian distribution of women so if
you reduce those surplus population of
unpartnered young men they're not out
there committing young male syndrome
they're not um committing crime there
and they can actually focus on uh
helping their family and helping their
community and those cultures then thrive
so that's a widely understood concept in
the literature so
i think it was the
yeah just very taken out of context or
willfully uh misconstrued to paint him
in a bad light
yeah interesting
i like the idea of an ethical pickup
artist
although i suppose
i mean i wouldn't want to put my dad in
that category exactly but but like he
does try and teach people
particularly men but not just men how to
improve themselves in order to have
monogamous relationships so i guess
maybe i'll tell them that later
pick-up artist dad if he ever wants to
go into business
i'm available yeah
interesting when did um originally
are you that familiar with the kind of
pickup artist background like i i
remember i think it was it was something
like 2011 or 2010 there was one guy i
think he was in canada i can't remember
that kind of went viral
starting with an r rush or something um
okay
i remember reading neil strauss the game
when i was a teenager and listening to
yeah
and all that
okay okay and tucker max um
when did it go from was it always kind
of
viewed in a negative light
or was it okay to begin with and then
somehow it just
declined into toxicity i mean maybe
looking back through the rear view
mirror you can maybe see some of the
toxic elements to it kind of gamifying
the system but i mean you know all
mating is you could conceptualize it as
a bit of a game there are rules there
yeah
strategies that work better and don't
work and you know things you can learn
about it but it just maybe over gamified
the whole thing and dehumanize the thing
a bit more but it's funny because yeah
whenever i talk about
online when i use
psychological literature terminology
like make value and make preferences
some people like extreme leftists maybe
come on and say
uh there's no such thing as mate value
and this sexual economics theory of
an economic kind of trade-off in the
amazing market in the mating market it's
all so ugly it's and it doesn't work
like that and i would just like to say
to those people how do you make your
amazing decisions just completely
arbitrarily just i'll pick whoever i
happen to pick of course you have rules
and what those rules are might change
and you might reward different things
and we can talk about whether those are
good bad whatever but there are some
rules there's always it's a you know it
is an amazing market people compete in
it and are selected from it so it's an
absolutely amazing market and
yeah people have different value in that
for various different reasons
yeah
yeah
that could go badly too because then you
could say okay well wearing makeup
making yourself look good as a woman
making yourself look good okay that's
that's got to play a role and then you
could
delve even deeper and be like well what
if men who work out in order to look
better is that manipulative
it's like
well maybe i guess but then is
everything manipulative and if
everything is then maybe none of it is
exciting
i mean like there's a really good paper
by my former supervisor andrew thomas uh
i think it's called the ape i thought it
was a peacock and it highlights how
evolutionary psychology uh used to maybe
have the dominant theory of uh males
compete females choose and it talks
about how females are the sexual
selectors and males compete but if that
was true then
females the human female would be drab
and completely
not ornate never do themselves up and
just go to the nightclub in their
pajamas and just select the whatever man
they want like look at a peacock it's so
much so bright and colorful compared to
the drab p hen but in humans that's not
the case so he developed a new theory of
a mutual mate choice so females compete
perhaps just as aggressively for male
selection
as female uh as men do for female
selection maybe not as much but
yeah yeah well i can see that i mean
being a female in high school is rough
right i think it's rough for everybody
women can be unbelievably mean to each
other
yeah and it's usually around kind of me
whenever either sex insults each other
and when men insult other men and women
insults other women it's usually to do
with mating relevant information so
women say oh you [ __ ] she's easy she's a
kind of lowering her value there whereas
men might say oh he's a [ __ ] or he's
not a real man and it's kind of lowering
of what's valuable to the other sex
amazing domain it's all
it's always relevant to basically
everything
that is so cool um that's so fun i'm
going to ask you one more question then
i'm going to let you go
you said hypergamy so marrying up might
be in decline is that true and why would
that be true i mean
there's evidence to show that and and
my opinion that's what's the what's the
evidence to show that so
there's
a paper called the decline of hypergamy
i believe i'm just trying to end up
aptly named
yeah and so
i think it's inevitable because when
more and more women are earning more
than men and higher educated if their
choice is to be single or to make down i
think a lot of them will choose to make
down or certainly more and more of them
right you know that that trend doesn't
seem that
that seems intuitive to me but it's what
happens alongside that so i mentioned
the internet partner violence as one
unfortunate finding
alongside that but also there's some
evidence and uh
my supervisor and i maybe disagree on
how much to trust this evidence he's
more um
cynical than me on this line of evidence
but there's some evidence that the
decline in hypergamy uh happens in
lockstep with increases in rates of
female infidelity so rates of infidelity
for men have remained pretty stable over
time but they've increased by 40 percent
among women in the last half century so
women specifically and that makes a bit
of sense if you think well women now
have anonymity of dating apps maybe
they're surrounded by more high status
men they're not as financially dependent
but then
i'd be i'd share my supervisor's
cynicism that
the gap of male infidelity versus female
infidelity will totally close i think
you know even with this massive increase
women still only
if if we took that as uh real
women would still only commit infidelity
70 percent as much as men so it's still
still even a huge increase for women men
are still
bigger dogs
do you think
do you think that increase could be
caused by less respect
as well
well less respect are you just less
reliant you know you're around more high
schools men and even just proximity
breeds intimacy
a lot anyway so you kind of tend to fall
in love with the people you're around a
lot and workplace romances happened a
lot in our history and they're kind of
frowned upon completely now which is
how a lot of people tended to meet in
the past and uh
that's kind of a dodgy one because that
idea of proximity breeds intimacy is
true so people are going to develop
feelings with their colleagues or their
classmates and things like that but it's
kind of fraught territory now
um so yeah that's going on the less
reliance on their man so traditionally
maybe women couldn't afford to have an
affair because it would
perhaps inflict such a cost you know you
might if you're left or whatever you
might not
have the financial resources to manage
on your own things like that so all of
that's kind of coming into play
do you think this uh increase in
interpersonal
violence um amongst couples that where
the woman out earns the man do you think
that could also be kind of a
because of frustration or another way to
assert dominance like obviously not a
good way but being like okay well i'm
not dominant in the in the money area
i'll be dominant in the physical
strength area yeah that's exactly right
because in evolutionary psychology we
have mate retention and you have tacked
two tactics for mate retention you can
benefit provide you can be a provision
benefit so those who have a lot of
benefit to provide will choose that
strategy whereas if you don't have a lot
of benefit to provide you'll cost
inflict you'll apply cost inflicting
retention strategies so you'll make it
so hard for the woman to leave and
that's what like abusive partners do
they just make it
so hard and you know even stalking for
example which is a overwhelmingly male
pattern of behavior and that's
most often done by an ex-partner and the
idea is that it makes it so difficult
for the woman to move on with her life
and it actually one of disturbing
findings from
dr buss's lab is that stalking works and
an unfortunate finding is that women who
are stalked often go back to their
partner and precisely because the man is
just making it so costly uh you know for
another future mate yeah who's gonna get
involved with a woman who her ex is
gonna be always around the house and
gonna beat you up or maybe kill you you
know
and if you think about ancestrally that
would have really worked now you might
land yourself in prison and things like
that but being a stalker in our
ancestral environment might have really
worked because you know
it was a bit more lawless
interesting
so that's how that tactic works yeah and
certainly so for men who are getting the
cue that their partner is around other
high status men not as reliant on them
doesn't really need them they're kind of
thinking oh
i might
i'm getting desperate and it's when a
man feels like he's about to lose a
partner that's when he gets violent and
dangerous so
it's a it's not it's something worth
thinking about yeah
wow
okay i feel like that happens more than
we think it does yeah certainly and i
think people who work in like social
work will maybe recognize that and they
might frame it as precarious masculinity
when a man doesn't feel like a man well
what perhaps is going to make a man not
feel like a man a lot is his partner
earning more than them or you know he
him not having access to status and you
know masculinity is kind of demeaned
culturally a little bit too so and you
know so
okay okay
here's a good question then here's
here's my last question uh are there
ways around this say that you're with
somebody and the females out earning the
mail which is bound to happen are there
ways that you can kind of assert
dominance as a man without just
beating your significant other over
resorting to stalking right have you
heard of any like tricks
so i would like say that yeah you can
create any amount of status domains now
so okay your man might not be the best
um
high status in his workplace but he
could be high status in your dance club
that you go to or in your
art or whatever it might be and
then it it's kind of a pathway for both
to see each other
for each partner to see him in a high
status kind of light and as long as the
man feels maybe seen as high status and
some to some degree and i can just
imagine a lot of listeners being like oh
the weak-minded man needs to be seen as
important well yeah and
for the woman too though like in a
relationship
prefers to admire her partner so find
some avenue to do that it could be
sexually it could be socially it could
be sport it could be dance art
whatever it might be but unfortunately a
lot of men's hobbies now tends to be
computer games right and i don't think
women are that not ideal
right now
and so that's another
cultural phenomenon that's maybe
driving sexes against each other a
little bit yeah i i don't think there's
many uh maybe i'm wrong there might be a
fandom of women who are interested in
computer gamers and stuff like that but
i don't think it's quite typical
i don't think i don't think it's quite
typical either that's sneaky though just
find it a different
area to kind of play a dominance
game there right you can create any
status
okay i like it okay william uh that was
very interesting thank you if people
want to follow you online or learn more
about this are there things they should
read or social media handles you have
sure so our first paper from my master's
dissertation on in cell psychology some
of the findings that i talked about
today is coming out soon it's currently
in press at the journal evolutionary
psychological science and uh to keep an
eye on me i
spend far too much time on twitter so my
handle is at costello william and uh
yeah you'll keep uh you'll have an idea
of everything i'm up to by following me
on there
okay cool
cool well send me over that when it's
published
i'll link it in the video great that's
very cool congratulations thank you yeah
first publications on over the moon with
that one wow okay okay thank you again
thanks michaela bye-bye